justement continuer à parler
de cette cérémonie exceptionnelle hors
norme avec notre invité nous sommes en
ligne avec virginie martin politologue
elle virginie martin bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on a vu
les personnes mobilisées durant est la
crise sanitaire était à l'honneur
aujourd'hui
pour cette cérémonie du 14 juillet
qu'elle portait peut-on accorder à cet
hommage à exceptionnel écoutez il ya de
toute façon une instrumentalisation
toujours politique bien sûr de ce genre
dommage puisque là on a vu c'est une
séquence émotion très forte
et finalement on le sait très bien en
communication politique une fois qu'on
joue la carte de l'émotion
vous comprenez bien que le cérébral se
met sur postes et on ne va plus osé
critiquer donc finalement l'émotion sert
évidemment à une baisse de la vigilance
politique d'une part et aussi finalement
à travailler l'unité potentiel putative
d'un pays en termes de communication ça
marche toujours très bien et puis
évidemment derrière on voit bien qu'à un
grand contraste entre ce très bel
hommage c'est speed hier et la réalité
des hôpitaux et la réalité de ce qui se
passe sur le terrain
donc c'est toujours un petit peu
évidemment au mieux à de force et
l'image et forcé le trait mais c'est
utile en termes de communication
politique d'antan 2 est-ce que voilà la
communication politique sera également
au coeur de cette interview qui aura
lieu en mi journée
que va chercher à faire le chef de
l'état durant cet entretien à votre avis
un peu ce qu'il fait depuis ce matin
c'est à dire créer de l'unité essayer
justement de donjons béon définitive les
problèmes c'est à dire à la fois ou
plutôt ses échecs c'est à dire par
exemple les municipales ne lui ont pas
été favorables c'est comme si elle
n'avait pas existé il les a très très
vite en jambes et là aujourd'hui on a un
grand contraste ont alors trop n'a
l'autorité on a des choses très bien
réglée alors que pendant justement la
crise du coc vide il ya eu le désordre
les errances les hésitations ça a été
véritablement très conflictuelle et là
tout d'un coup il ne se passe plus rien
on gomme donc le prison d'un public aime
beaucoup à enjamber comme ça les
problèmes et ce qui ne lui est pas
finalement favorable d'autant plus qu'
il ya eu évidemment là le triple
avantage du triple anniversaire de de
gaulle donc de sa mort de sa naissance
et du 18 juin 40
donc là aussi emmanuel macron à chercher
encore à retrouver de la verticalité et
ne jamais surtout perdre cette
verticalité jupitérienne qui lui tient
tant à coeur
maintenant sur le discours de tout à
l'heure on va enfin peut-être avoir un
discours de cadrage puisqu'on voit bien
que les nouveaux ministres et notamment
le premier ministre le nouveau premier
ministre l'a finalement s'agite un peu
dans le pays par tous en guyane et c'est
parce que finalement il n'a pas eu le
droit de prononcer son discours de
politique générale puisque le président
de la république doit parler en premier
donc c'est aujourd'hui qu'il va parler
il est temps il est temps de raconter ce
nouveau chemin 1
mais ce nouveau chemin aussi contraste
et va sûrement contrasté avec ce qu'on
voit ce matin et la réalité de toute
façon du pays à la fois économique
sociale en termes d'unités et en termes
de santé aussi puisque le co vide
revient visiblement emmanuel macron
renault on l'a dit avec un exercice de
communication dont il ne voulait plus
entendre parler
une manière pour lui de reprendre les
choses en main c'est une manière surtout
de se poser on est rouge de guerre
finalement est aujourd'hui évidemment
c'est tout un propos puisque rappelez
vous il avait dit le la lutte contre le
coronavirus c'est une guerre c'est une
guerre est là aujourd'hui il se pose en
héros comme si nous avions finalement
signé une armistice avec le co vite ce
qui n'est évidemment pas le cas donc que
c'est un peu paradoxal et avec sur son
anglais un peu approximatif qui dit
aussi à garder des anglophones de la
salle à will be d'air india webinaire
d'ailleurs mais bon passons
mais est donc ça fait un peu un
terminator comme ça et est un peu héros
de guerre justement est tout droit tirée
d'un film hollywoodien
donc c'est toujours cette place qui lui
tient à coeur et on voit bien finalement
ça lui va très bien de remettre à
l'honneur ce discours et 7 cette
interview du 14 juillet je pense que
c'était plutôt un effet de volonté de
démocratie de 2,2 d'empathie avec le
peuple qui ne lui a filé finalement pas
je trouve qu'il est mieux qu'il soit
dans son exercice finalement d'autorité
jupitérienne et qu'il dise qu'il est
avec cette interview du 14 juillet ça me
paraît beaucoup plus raccord avec le
personnage et l'exercice de son pouvoir
est ce que le chef de l'état essaie de
se donner une stature d'homme d'état
justement avec voilà cet hommage aussi
qui a été rendu aujourd'hui la figure
historique du général de gaulle il
essaye de reprendre un petit peu c'est
pas oui j'en parlais tout à l'heure il a
la chance encore une fois elle ces
planètes sont très bien alignées et donc
finalement ce triple hommage donc
aujourd'hui au général de gaulle donc de
sa mort de sa naissance et du 18 juin 40
sont très importants parce que
finalement sans le dire dans les
imageries et la symbolique est bien le
long ils arrivent à se mettre dans les
parent alors dans les représentations
vous voyez inconscient au quart de nos
cerveaux et de nos esprits tout ça
finira de toute façon peu ou prou par
plus ou moins
cool et ça c'est très important d'une
part et ça permet aussi de se poser au
dessus de l'histoire ou deux au delà de
l'histoire du quotidien au delà des jets
les jeunes au delà des conflits au delà
du problème des retraites au delà du coc
vide
au delà de tout d'un coup on rend dans
la grande histoire dans l'histoire
gaullienne gaulliste et donc les manuels
macro lui rend hommage
ceci dit c'est normal mais bon on voit
bien que ça n'arrive pas de n'importe
quoi aussi et c'est une occasion aussi
de dépolitiser ce qu'il se passe en
france aujourd'hui dépolitiser pour
remettre la grande histoire d'un côté
avec de gaulle l'émotion avec les
soignants de l'aude ont des politiques
le débat c'est le quotidien des français
qui risque d'être un petit peu perturbé
les prochains jours des manifestations
encore avec le personnel hospitalier qui
va manifester cet après midi qui n'est
pas totalement convaincu par le ségur de
la santé la réforme des retraites qui va
être un dossier important du
gouvernement
castex sûrement à la rentrée il reste
deux ans à emmanuel macron à la tête du
pays
quelles vont être les défis à relever
selon vo les défis je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il ait envie d affronter parce que
les vrais des filles c'est retrouver
l'unité du pays
l'unité du pays est véritablement dans
un état pitoyable depuis trois ans et
c'est ça le vrai défi et je ne suis pas
sûr que ce ça se soit finalement ce plat
qui importe vraiment emmanuel macron en
tout cas il n'en montre pas les signes
on a plutôt l'impression qu'il fait un
peut être un calcul plus politicien de
dire finalement dans ce pays aujourd'hui
au regard du nombre de votants
il suffit d'avoir 15 20 23 % de gens qui
votent pour vous au premier tour à la
présidentielle
et ça passe et ça passe donc finalement
on a plutôt l'impression qui vient
câline et cajolé rassurer ses 20%
d'électeurs putatif qui pourrait lui
apporter son soutien leur soutien par
don dès le premier tour et la square
aujourd'hui ce sont des électeurs
plus conservateurs ce sont des électeurs
de droite sont des électeurs qui se
disent libéraux du point de vue
économique
et là on voit bien beaucoup plus
conservateur du point de vue sociétal
alors qu'emmanuel la cour se disait
ouvert du point de vue sociétal
on voit bien aujourd'hui avec les
nominations de dupond moretti d'un côté
de dharmanand de l'autre on voit bien
qu'il n'ya pas grand-chose de libéral
sur les sur les idées des moeurs puisque
évidemment ça véhicule au contraire
sexisme patriarcat donc des choses très
classique très conservatrice et très un
peu old school si je puis dire mais ça
permet de gagner l'électorat qui votent
et ça c'est très important celui des
personnes âgées celui des gens de droite
celui des gens très inclus dans la
société qui sont peu abstentionnistes
donc normalement
la tâche du président république devrait
peut-être retrouver l'unité refaire
l'unité dans la nation mais il me semble
je crains qu'il s'intéresse plutôt à la
présidentielle à venir et donc à des
tactiques plus politiciennes et de
communication politique
merci beaucoup mais un jeune et martin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue